hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into
practice I've studied and taught
Philosophy for over 20 years and I find
that many people run into difficulties
reading classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured but the
concepts themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to helps students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them
useful what you're currently watching is
part of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on One Core concept
from an important philosophical text I
hope you find it useful as
well many people programs
organizations parties will make an
appeal to the language of virtue in our
contemporary society as if it's very
straightforward and there's consensus
across the society at least among
right-thinking people about these
matters and Alistair McIntyre is going
to go directly after them in his essay
how to seem
virtuous without actually being so he is
going to be criticizing what we can call
the
facade the appearance without the
reality of moral consensus about the
nature of the virtues what these terms
mean how to bring them about in people
through say moral education or
legislation or even just
recommending character development and
modeling ourselves after people that we
identify as virtuous and he begins this
essay by talking about a distinct iction
that anybody who really cares about the
virtues will want to make he says that
the adherence of any tolerably
systematic and coherent account of the
virtues which they believe to be
rationally defensible let we pause on
that for a moment if you're going to
have an account of the virtues and
you're not going to be full of
BS then it has to be rationally
defensible you have to be able to
explain it to other people in ways that
at least if they're being good faith
interlocutors they could say aha yeah I
see why you're saying that you can't
just go by your gut you can't just
appeal to sentiment and feeling and you
want it to be tolerably systematic and
coherent you don't want a mishmash or
very superficial treatment of these
sorts of matters now what's the
distinction between genuine virtues
people actually having good states of
character and the
counterfeits of those virtues and what
would that be so he uses examples a
little bit later on let's take courage
right a person that we ascribe courage
to may not actually be courageous in any
real sense they may not have that as a
disposition that they have developed
over time which can be reliably counted
on to you know behave in the right ways
in different
situations and we're going to talk about
some of the qualifiers for that many
people are ascribed virtues by other
people that they don't even remotely
have they just have sort of like it's
almost like the old game of pin the tail
on the donkey you're kind of blindfolded
and you stick something in maybe it's
maybe you got the donkey's uh butt and
tail lined up correctly or maybe you
don't but people just kind of throw
these terms around pretty willy-nilly to
the point where you can have like flash
cards and they're used in Elementary
School classrooms and you hand them out
to the students oo you were generous
today right no you may not actually be
generous you might have just loed out at
that point in time so what is our
current situation in the society that we
inhabit McIntyre's general idea about
this can be found in works like after
virtue but he's going to tell us some
things here about that and he tells us
that we have rival and incompatible
accounts of the virtues floating around
out there among actual systematic and
coherent accounts we're not actually
talking about our shared public morality
which doesn't exist
yet but there are you know a number of
different more or less substantive
Notions
systems of what the virtues would be and
they are not all compatible with each
other he also goes on and he says that
despite people's claims to the opposite
there can be no rationally defensive
shared program for moral education uh
for our society as such but only a
number of rival and conflicting programs
each from the standpoint of one specific
conten view so we have this set of
different rival versions of morality out
there and they you know they're
incompatible with each other that's the
reality that we inhabit we also don't
have a shared morality as so many people
love to pretend oh can't we all agree
that no McIntyre is saying we can't all
agree not if we're actually being
truthful and thinking things through and
being being diligent and making words
mean something other than just what we
want them to mean right now so where
does this consensus this fake consensus
come from he goes on and he says that um
the proponents of shared public moral
education and they are enormously
influential insist that we do in fact
share a morality and so he says my first
task is to explain why it is they're
successfully able to deceive both
themselves and others on this and
Kindred topics and he says I'm going to
suggest that they're able to do so
because Society does not share a
morality an actual ethic in general what
we do share is something quite different
the spokespersons for our political
culture and Their audience share what he
calls
a rhetoric a persuasive use of language
now a rhetoric is not the same thing as
a morality right or an Ethics a rhetoric
is you could think of it as a bunch of
different connected techniques and
sentiments that allow us to push certain
buttons and get certain
results and so he says that they they
share a moral rhetoric and he says how
that rhetoric differs in its treatment
of the virtues from any rational
defensible systematic account of the
virtues is my opening question how how
does this rhetoric differ from actual
conflicting
moralities and so he talks about a
commonplace rhetorical usage of virtue
words so what are virtue words words
that uh name certain things that we call
virtues he talks about uh calling people
Brave or generous or just
um and you know we we say that because
somebody on a limited but sufficiently
numerous range of occasions has done
particular Brave or generous or just
actions and they haven't done any
clearly uh you know opposite actions a
subtle disposition to act is ascribed
right so there's a language out there
that used to mean something more used to
name something more
specific and you know it's it's
available for
usage um so common place he goes and
clarifies that he says in the
Contemporary public Metropolitan
cultures of the so-called Advanced
societies such as our own so you know
you could take this as applying to the
they call them weird countries right uh
those of liberal democracies in the 20th
and 21st century that have you know
capitalist uh economies and and
relatively high standards of living
right but have had a moral breakdown in
um any sort of consensus about what
morality actually is there's still this
commonplace rhetorical usage how do you
know this is the case use the word
courageous use the word brave use the
word just use the word integrity use the
word generosity and people have these
warm fuzzy associations with them they
may say well that person over there
isn't generous but it's really good to
be generous but then you ask them great
what is generosity actually mean what
does it involve and they're like well
you know it's like you give to people
okay give to people in which
circumstances in which ways how what
kind of things are you giving to them I
don't know about that right then people
get very flustered because they don't
have any coherent systematic account of
what the those virtues are or what their
opposites would be and so McIntyre is
going to say they're using these words
to ascribe dispositions good
dispositions to people that we should
model ourselves after they are not
actually ascribing the same disposition
as say an Aristotelian virtue ethicist
would be to those people because
Aristotle actually and Neo aristotelians
like McIntyre actually have some pretty
solid conceptions of what that involves
he says the same sentences are being
employed but the judgments to which they
give expression are in fact quite
different and he says where does the
difference lie and so here's where we
get to some four questions that he
identifies as being particularly
important and we're going to discuss
this elsewhere so I'm not going to go
into these in sufficient depth right
here but we can say that the first
question has to do with counterfactuals
the person behaves this way in this
situation how would they have behaved if
we tweaked the situation and change some
of the variables some of the parameters
some of the circumstances how will they
behave in the future in similar things
what reasons do they have for behaving
the way that they do for making the
choices they do what sort of things do
they feel or desire or are averse to
what kinds of pleasures and pains do
they have acting in certain ways and
then finally we want if we want actual
virtues we want things that transfer
across different situations and McIntyre
is going to tell us that any real ethics
provides an answer to those when it
comes to the virtues but what happens
with the sort of
commonplace uh you know moral consensus
that's just an appearance not a reality
which is essentially a counterfeit
morality uh he goes on and he tells us
that um the answers provided by
commonplace usage are as he calls it
highly indeterminate what does highly
indeterminate mean they're not well
worked out they are fuzzy they don't
have Precision because they're not
really addressing these sorts of
questions so he says that um
[Music]
here we go uh the answers supplied by
commonplace usage are highly
indeterminate to call someone Brave or
generous or just according to the mode
of present day commonplace usage is to
leave largely open and
undecided what answers are to be given
to these questions so they're not
answering the questions they're saying H
you know you can kind of figure that out
out later on down the line and he goes
on and he says this indeterminacy in
respect of what's entailed or implied by
judgments that some particular person is
virtuous uh an indeterminacy of meaning
equivocation we could actually say has
two alternating aspects and so he notes
a paradox or contradiction here so one
of these is that on the one hand in so
far as commonplace usage concerning the
virtues merely leaves open and
unanswered to some large degree these
questions commonplace usage appears more
or less consistent with all in any of
those rival systematic conceptions it'll
take on any of them ah you could be an
Aristotelian you could be a stoic you
could be some sort of Christian virtue
ethesis ah it's all the same it it all
works out just fine right because you're
not getting specific particular
systematic enough and and therefore
you're actually generating counterfeits
to the virtues on the other hand
McIntyre points out and I think this is
particularly
important he says as commonplace usage
functions so as to embody a
silent but insistent and continuing
refusal to supply answers to those same
four questions it appears to be equally
inconsistent
with any one of them right so there's a
uh as he calls it alternating and
incompatible set of aspects there the
shallow superficial appeals to virtues
that we see so many
organizations so many programs so many
people making winds up totally
incoherent and blocking the way to any
genuine treatment of Virtues and so here
we can talk about a gap as
McIntyre uh you know brings this this
section to a close with he says a large
and largely unnoticed Gap exists between
the nature and grounds of those
descriptions of the virtues figuring so
notably in commonplace usage and public
political rhetoric and those verbally
similar scriptions giving expression to
some systematic and coherent account of
the virtues and why is this Gap in place
because it has a useful function for
those who want to indulge themselves in
this he says that um it functions so as
to protect from scrutiny the
presentation of self in contemporary
public and political life of those
holding and aspiring to public office so
anybody can make claims about virtues
and if you call them on it well because
it's all kind of Loosey Goosey because
it's all superficial because it is
refusing to answer these important
questions anything can be turned into
anything right and we see this all the
time people who we uh have uh viewed as
being virtuous in certain respects turn
out to be complete scumbags because they
weren't virtuous at all it was just
people calling them as such and that is
one of the functions of this Gap so he
says that appearance and that rhetoric
are well served by the indeterminacy of
The Virtue concepts of contemporary cont
uh uh commonplace usage so this is a big
problem we don't really have any sort of
moral consensus what we do have is much
more superficial a shared rhetoric which
can be turned to all sorts of uses to
make people to go back to the
title allow them to appear virtuous
without actually being so and then not
get called on it because that
conversational space which should be
occupied by more robust virtue theories
is instead occupied by people employing
this superficial shared rhetoric of
virtue
that